oui bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
federica bonjour j mee bonjour didier
laguerre bonjour ébauche aux auditrices
et auditeurs ne manquait que la première
didier laguerre maire de fort de france
vice président de la cacem membre du
bureau politique du pp m
non non vous n'êtes pas membre du comité
national du comité national voilà
exactement donc mais enfin vous êtes
quand même dans les instances
dirigeantes du ppm voilà ce qu'il faut
retenir justement le ppm en proie à
quelques vicissitudes on va commencer
par l'actualité de ces derniers jours
didier laguerre rodolphe désiré maire en
exercice du marin et président d'honneur
me semble-t-il très juin d'honneur du
ppm voilà président d'honneur du ppm
inquiété par la justice
tout récemment mise en examen un coup
dur incontestablement peut-être pour le
parti progressiste martiniquais qui est
dans la tourmente
non le parti progressiste martiniquais
n'est pas dans la tourmente vous savez
moi je commencerais pas apporter mon
soutien personnel à odos dédié à la mode
off disiez vous savez au dolce et un
combattant un vieux combattant qui a
l'habitude de relever les défis je lui
fais confiance pour relever ce défi et
pour répondre à ses obligations et ainsi
montrer qu'il n'a pas n'a rien à se
reprocher dans cette affaire
maintenant vous savez quand vous être
maire d'une commune
vous êtes tous les joueurs susceptibles
d'être appelés en responsabilité pour
diverses raisons
donc aujourd'hui au d'olf désiré est
appelée dans une affaire qui a été
médiatisé qui était publié cite un
communiqué du procureur il est pour quoi
que ce soit médiatisé je dis juste il
l'est dans un dossier il a été mis en
examen la justice fera son travail ou de
l'oeuf
fera ce qu'il a à faire pour se défendre
dans cette affaire pour l'avc défi voulu
maintenez votre confiance moral j'ai
envie de dire oui vous doivent désigner
quelqu'un que je connais depuis depuis
longtemps que je respecte et je lui
confiais chez lui mais tiens oui ma
confiance moelle et mon soutien
personnel dans cette épreuve qui l'a
qu'il a affronté je pense qu'il saura
faire face et qu'il saura affronter ce
nouveau défi alors vous même didier
laguerre avait été récemment aussi mis
sur la sellette alors pour tout autre
chose
à la suite du tournage d'un clip du
chanteur martiniquais de style dancehall
reggae kalach oui quelques-uns de vos
administrés et des policiers même se
sont émus et même certains se sont
plaints parmi donc certains résidants du
quartier de sainte thérèse où a eu lieu
le tournage du clip se sont plaints de
votre autorisation municipale disait
calage données en 48 heures je crois
c'est ça entre sa demande et votre
autorisation obtenue pour ce tournage
alors aux suites donc je les dis un peu
bruyante dans le quartier de
sainte-thérèse et on vous a on a
reproché à l'équipe de tournage de
d'avoir filmé des images de motards sans
casque
voilà alors vous vous avez réagi dans un
tweet récemment je crois je recherche et
vous avez dit je refuse l'amalgamé
cultures urbaines violence la culture
urbaine ne se réduit pas à la musique et
l'amalgamé souvent un motif pour rejeter
la jeunesse voilà vous dit avoir
confiance et vous dit autoriser
l'expression que c'est autoriser
l'expression c'est ouvrir la possibilité
du dialogue avec la jeunesse
exactement je réagis ce tweet a été
diffusée y ait un
suite aux débats du conseil municipal et
à cette question qui a été évoqué par au
détour d'une question sur sur la
communication dont vous ne regrettez pas
d'avoir donné l'autorisation municipale
de lenval tournage de ce clip de
calmants pas du tout pas du tout au
contraire
bien au contraire de quoi parlons nous
parlons d'une société de production
parce que si le clip de l'artiste kalach
ça aurait pu être le pli
de n'importe quel artiste nous parlons
d'une société de production qui
interpelle alkalaj qui défraie la
chronique
quand même parfois pas toujours pour de
bonnes raisons je vous signale riz que
si vous faites référence à sa kalach est
aujourd'hui impliqué dans une affaire
judiciaire et que comme pour dol désigné
jean louis de l'uci ou tous ceux qui
sont impliqués dans des affaires
judiciaires jusqu'à leur condamnation
ils sont présumés innocents bien vous
avez une société de production
internationale qui interpelle la ville
et qui demande une autorisation de
tournage d'une partie de clips de clips
sur le domaine public
mo nous mobilisant 150 motos d'accord
cette société vous explique qu'elle fait
cette demande très tardive parce que
compte tenu de la notoriété de l'artiste
dans les quartiers en martinique et dans
le monde elle qu'elle craignait que plus
de motos que ce qui est prévu de le
tournage du clip ne soit présent elle a
donc les nouvelles halles est maintenue
secrète la venue de l'artiste en
martinique et est là elle s'est imposée
ce délai qu à partir de laquelle sont on
parlait tout à l'heure des
responsabilités quelles sont les
solutions qui s'offrent aux mai à la
foire de france
vous en avez 2 et maire de fort de
france refuse cette autorisation
il prend le risque que les clips les
images la manifestation soit organisée
sans autorisation sur la voie publique
comme ça a déjà été le cas
comme c'est le cas très souvent dans le
cadre des clips qui sont tournés en
martinique avec en cas d'accident leurs
proches qui pourraient légitimement lui
est fait d'être au courant est formé de
l'organisation de ce tournage et de
n'avoir pris aucune mesure
mais vous vous êtes un peu inquiété des
conditions de hatha yoga la toya tant
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup je vais y aller
donc qu'est ce que je fais j'autorise le
tournage du clip et j'ai posé un certain
nombre de conditions pas d'alcool pas de
drogue pas d'armes je pose un horaire
qui se fait en journée qui est chargée
de contrôler nos françoise municipal
la société de production associés la
police municipale est présente sur les
lieux et nous avons l'adjoint au maire
de fort de france en charge de la
sécurité un certain de personnes
commissaire de police ex iter qui sont
pris les choses se passent très bien
maintenant sur le fond là où on a
tendance à vouloir aller si vouloir
rejeter un certain nombre d'artistes qui
peuvent être qu'on trouvait assez avec
il faut peut être discutée mais rejeté
un certain nombre d'artistes et par là
même toute une frange de la jeunesse
parce que ces artistes ont aussi une
audience ce faisant vous vous rompez le
dialogue avec eux accepté donné
l'autorisation
justement discuter avec les conseils
citoyens avec les policiers et avec la
société de production avec l'artiste sur
les conséquences de ce qu'ils font sur
l'impact que cela peut avoir
peut nous permettre d'avancer alors que
refuser c'est simplement braquer une
partie de la jeunesse celle qui est
justement qu'ils écoutent ces musiques
là qui coûte ses formes de culture c'est
rejeter et de crier encore davantage de
distances de défiance et au final
peut-être davantage de violence donc
finalement vous assumer la prise de
risque oui je m'attends à ce type déjà
subi la prise de risques comme j'assume
la prise de risque inhérente à au
concert de calage sur la savane avec
30000 personnes comme j'assume la prise
de risque de la carte jeunes qui très
souvent reproché au maire de fort de
france organisé sur la savane pendant
pendant le festival
mais si si nous ne prenons pas ces
risques là en tant qu'élus nous privons
cette jeunesse d'une forme d'expression
tout simplement didier laguerre autres
polémiques voire même passe d'armes
politique avec notamment la majorité à
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique le fameux musée d'art
contemporain qui que la ctm veut
installer dans les murs d'un de ces
bâtiments l'ex palais de justice mais il
ya une convention est donc le sermac
occupe occupe ses locaux alors vous vous
parlez d'une spoliation par la ctm d'un
bâtiment de la ville
là encore c'est un tweet tout récent nir
qui là encore ce sont des propos que
j'ai tenus au conseil municipal suite à
une interpellation dossier qui n'avait
strictement rien à voir comme vous
n'avez pas le temps je vous la fais
encore la ctm veut spolier la vie
je vais vous la faire deux minutes début
des années 2000 l'état a besoin de
terrains pour construire la cour d'appel
l'état demande à la ville de
l'accompagner la ville cède gratuitement
les terrains de l'ex que les journaux en
contrepartie l'état doit céder
gratuitement à la ville les terrains de
l'exode harmonie qui a été démoli par la
ville et les t1 et le t1 du palais de
justice l'état tient ses engagements en
transférant au conseil général le
conseil général doit transférer à la
ville délibérations à l'appui la ctm qui
prend la suite du conseil général fait
une proposition suite au conseil général
de cession du bâtiment à deux millions
d'euros
la ville a réalisé un mignon travaux
dans le bâtiment je demande donc à
minima une réduction de 1 million du
prix la réponse qui m'est fait je vous
propose le bâtiment de l'union que dites
vous en février 2019 j'accepte la
cession à 2 millions d'euros alors que
elle devait avoir lieu à titre gratuit
et en juillet 2019 on m'écrit pour me
dire qu'on annule la convention et que
on me demande de libérer le bâtiment au
31 octobre 2010 la 7e étape dans son bon
droit la non avait il indiqué sur le
plan juridique le tribunal administratif
diva c'est la septième est dans son bon
droit
vous avez porté plainte en absolu de
recettes j'ai attaqué la délibération du
taux de l'assemblée de martinique et
j'attends dira sereinement que la
justice dise qui a raison et surtout
j'attends que des ces conditions l'état
se prononce sur le paiement des terrains
d'assiette de la cour d'appel parce que
l'état a bénéficié de soutiens à titre
gratuit la ville en contrepartie n'a pas
le paiement très vite que l'ue était du
jeu lé rappeler en début d'émission vous
êtes vice président de la cacem la
communauté d'agglomération du centre de
la martinique qui regroupe saint joseph
le lamantin schoelcher et fort de france
la cacem qui on a l'impression et est un
outil
un peu enrayer une machine outil un peu
enrayée depuis la condamnation en mai
dernier date and haas jeanne rose pour
escroquerie alors il a fait un pourvoi
en cassation sa suspens sont la décision
judiciaire de son inégibilité
inégibilité mais lui qui est le
président de la cacem on le voit plus
beaucoup et puis on a l'impression que
bon voilà quoi
il faut lui poser la question oui alors
il faut lui poser la question
vous qui êtes vice-président et vous
avez un conseiller municipal est aussi
un conseiller communautaire en la
personne de l'ubs de grandmaison qui lui
a souhaité il ya quelques mois ici même
dans ce cas dit qu'ils souhaitaient la
démission de dettes à nazran rose il
disait que moralement ce serait mieux
quoi mais que ça faciliterait le
fonctionnement de la cacem je sais pas
si ça faciliterait le fonctionnement de
la caserne où vous dis là d'accord avec
la saison fonctionne avec le de
grandmaison je vais vous répondre
aujourd'hui la casse et le fonctionne la
cacem sur grigny la caspienne prend ses
décisions la cassine organiser la fête
du sport samedi dernier au port de
plaisance de l'étang à picot là
maintenant que je pense que oui on a une
problématique à ce niveau-là d'exercice
de certaines responsabilités alors qu on
a aussi des problématiques judiciaire et
que c'est une question de fond qu'il
faut qu'on se pose au niveau de la
cassine au niveau des élus martiniquais
d'une façon générale merci didier
laguerre d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin bonne journée merci bonne
journée à vous et bonne journée au
martiniquaise martin qui nous écoutent